rebaptise falvo aux merci d'être avec
nous alors sur le terrain tout d'abord
que sait-on des pertes aux russes alors
écoutez les chiffres officiels russes ne
font état que de 498 morts du côté des
soldats russes tués c'est un chiffre qui
n'a pas été réactualisé depuis le 2 mars
dernier ce qui montre qu'il a quand même
une gêne ou visiblement une volonté de
passer sous silence le nombre réel de
morts du côté du kremlin il ya des
chiffres qui sont parvenus à la presse
américaine par le biais des
renseignements américains hier qui me
parle de 7000 soldats russes tués au
front si ces chiffres sont confirmés on
ne peut pas les vérifier indépendamment
c'est difficile d'avoir des observateurs
derrière chaque colonne de chars russes
abattu par la défense ukrainienne mais
en tout cas s'ils sont confirmés il fera
par l'extrême rapidité avec laquelle ils
ont été atteints je voudrais qu'on
revienne juste sur la l'infographie
précédentes parce qu'on peut faire un
comparatif avec ce qui s'est passé
justement dans l'histoire des guerres
russe et notamment en afghanistan en
afghanistan il y avait quinze mille
morts du côté des troupes soviétiques en
dix ans donc vous imaginez la différence
aujourd'hui on parle de 7000 morts en
seulement trois semaines de conflit les
autres morts avaient été moins
meurtrière est effectivement donc les
chiffres occidentaux donné par les
renseignements occidentaux et russes
sont extrêmement divergents alors à côté
bien sûr de ses soldats tués au combat
on ne peut pas oublier les civils 726
civile ukrainiens auraient perdu la vie
selon les derniers chiffres de l'onu ça
encore ce sont des chiffres qu'il est
impossible de vérifier dans leur
exactitude mais ça montre l'ampleur du
conflit aujourd'hui et l'armée
ukrainienne semble techniquement plus
puissante que prévu shi jean ping et
schaub hayden doivent se parler en début
d'après midi et les etats unis menacent
la chine de représailles en cas d' aide
à la russie cette menace menacer la
chine est ce que c'est vraiment la
méthode la plus efficace en tout cas joe
biden visiblement estime que c'est le
moment ou jamais de mettre la pression
sur la chine à l'heure où les
renseignements américains laissent
entendre que pékin serait tenté
d'apporter une aide militaire ou au
moins économique à la russie joe biden
va certainement expliquer h et jean ping
que la chine a tout à perdre si elle
décide de soutenir la russie qui non
seulement n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on pouvait imaginer en termes
militaires et que finalement pécari se
retrouver du côté de ceux qui perdent et
puis bien sûr qu'il ya des soucis
sanctions occidentales qui peuvent être
prises contre la une sanction
supplémentaire puisqu'il y en a déjà
côté américain donc jusqu'ici la chine
marche sur un fil extrêmement ténus pour
préserver ses intérêts à savoir ne pas
lâcher la russie son analyse
circonstances notamment dans sa guerre
de bloc face aux états unis mais en même
temps ne pas passer pour un paria sur la
scène internationale et donc elle
s'abstient elle a un rôle un peu ambiguë
elle s'abstient de condamné l'invasion
russe en même temps le rappelle la
souveraineté ukrainienne elle critique
les sanctions occidentales à l'égard de
la russie donc très difficile de
connaître les intentions exactes de la
chine faut vraiment être un éminent
péchinot log pour savoir exactement ce
que la chine veut va-t-elle vraiment
apporter une aide à la russie va-t-elle
tenter d'alléger le fardeau des
sanctions économiques comme elle l'a
fait dans le passé avec l'iran ou avec
la corée du nord par exemple très
difficile de savoir il est surtout
possible que la chine attendent tout
simplement attendre de voir quelle
tournure va prendre la guerre pour être
entre guillemets du bon côté des
vainqueurs et donc elle reste
extrêmement prudentes pour le monde